key members of Congress are reacting to
the America first agenda the president
outlined in his speech to Congress the
chorus became an earthquake and the
people turned out by the tens of
millions and they were all united by one
very simple but crucial demand that
America must put its own citizens first
because only then can we truly make
America great again Republican Senator
Marco Rubio of Florida was inside the
house chamber last night for the
President's speech and he joins us now
from Capitol Hill good morning senator
good morning good morning let's start if
we can with the president's comments on
immigration mr. Trump said that he saw
the possibility of immigration reform as
long as American jobs and security come
first you've been part of a bipartisan
effort for immigration reform in the
past that that did not work out do you
think this could be successful at this
time now I do it's not gonna be easy but
I believe that and by the way that's the
what our immigration law should always
be about obviously number one is
ensuring the people that are entering
the United States whether permanently or
as visitors or people that are not going
to harm us and second that ensures that
it's good for our country and our
economy I think how you do it is going
to be the difficult part and what I've
encouraged the president and others is
to view this as a multi-step process
it begins with enforcing our laws so
that we can win the confidence of the
American people the second step would be
to modernize our system make it you know
less bureaucratic and and more
merit-based and the third is to deal
reasonably but responsibly with people
that are here that have been here a long
time who are not criminals who are in
violation of our immigration laws but
but who we should try to accommodate for
both humanitarian and economic purposes
I believe if we follow those steps and
in that order we can achieve a result
that's good for the country the
president made it clear that he intends
to repeal and replace Obamacare in your
state of Florida you have a the largest
number of residents on Obama care in the
country do his views reflect your own
about the changes he intends to make
well I absolutely believe Obamacare
needs to be repealed because a lot of
those people that are on Obama care and
I'm meeting with hospitals today about
this are truly uninsured
even though they have an Obamacare
coverage their premiums are sorry their
deductibles are so high you know that in
essence for them they'd have to spend
money they don't have before they can
even begin to use the plan now that
doesn't mean you throw those people out
in the street it doesn't mean we go back
to the system we had before 2010 I don't
want to go back to that either I want to
replace it with a system that for the
vast majority Americans means they're
going to be able to access private
health insurance that's more affordable
and covers the things they want in a
vibrant private marketplace did you like
what the president had to say last night
senator about that well he outlined
broad principles I picked the detail and
I think there's a great agreement over
those principles I think the the
difficult work is laying out exactly how
we achieve that away from the system but
certainly the principles that we don't
want to disrupt people that are on it
now that we certainly don't want to go
back to the old system because that
wasn't working either yes I agree with
those principles and they are were
guiding us and it's what I've been
talking about for 40 since 2014 I've had
a plan to replace Obamacare and I'll
work hard to make sure as many of those
elements are part of our law as possible
senator we spoke with your colleague
Senator Chuck Schumer earlier this
morning and he said that presidents
President Trump's words and actions have
not been consistent that he has done
nothing to actually foster unity among
opposing parties is that true well I
think the that is in the eye of the
beholder there's no doubt this president
has an unorthodox style and there's no
doubt that he enters our politics as
president at a time of extraordinary
division I would say that that would be
true on both sides if you saw last night
there was a moment after this president
spoke were a significant number of the
members has got up and walked out before
he had even finished the speech or just
as he barely finished it I don't do that
stuff other people have to speak for
themselves there's something the
president's done that people think is
divisive they'll have to ask him about
it I will tell you this I do believe
that for the good of the country we need
to give him a chance to be successful
and if we disagree with them you know
we'll take on those issues but I thought
last night was a very presidential
speech I thought last night was the best
speech I've seen him give and I've been
watching him now pretty closely for two
years and I don't think there's any
doubt about that and he did a very good
job last night and that was a promising
sign senator the president again called
for a trillion dollar spending program
on infrastructure at the same time he
called for significant tax cuts for
businesses are there the votes in
in Congress for an infrastructure
spending program well it depends so if
the trillion dollars are all taxpayer
money then I think that's going to be
very difficult for the reasons we've
outlined however as he discussed last
night and I think a lot of people missed
this point he talked about a
public-private partnership and if
they're talking about leveraging private
funds as a significant portion of that
trillion dollars over a 10 or 5-year
period I think that is very doable
within the context of it but of
everything else but it's going to
require us to allow the federal
government to with its limited resources
to focus on the things the federal
government is in charge of doing and
that is the national security of our
country the interstate infrastructure
that's necessary for our nation and a
safety net that helps people who are
fallen on hard times to stand up and try
again and that's what we'll have to work
hard to ensure that we can get back to
and I believe President didn't talk
about this but I believe that eventually
we will have to deal sooner rather than
later with reforms to save Social
Security and Medicare well Congress has
its marching orders Senator Marco Rubio
thanks for your time thank you